she does love going up the nose it's
like one of her favorite spots she is
six years old yeah I was gonna say six
years young butter loves to play fetch
she does love kisses she like loves
licking me everywhere and dress my
husband nuts but I like to let her
express herself she kisses everyone and
we actually trained her how to kiss so I
command Mesa teaching please oh thank
you as he likes to chew on toys she
loves to give kisses like big wet kisses
it's sort of like a storm of kisses she
will like lick my arm she'll smell my
mouth I won't let her like my mouth
because I see her lick her butthole
that's the weird thing we do it's just
like human kisses you know it's like a
sign of affection
maybe she makes my meeting system
stronger if I let her like like me I
hope so I have heard that dogs mouths
are cleaner than human's but I guess
some dog people don't get sick from
looking dogs mouths do they there's
nothing you could tell me that would
make me not want Lucy to give me kisses
I mean lucy has straight-up licked her
butt and then kissed me and it's fine Oh
about to get a reality check she does
shake when she goes to the vet so I
don't know if the code is getting off
anything
so I'm dr. Jody Pollard to meet you so I
heard she really likes to give kisses
how he does so did you know you could
possibly get parasites from her giving
kisses oh oh isn't that fine your dog
let's say is eating her own feces and
then she decides to go kiss you Oh God
parasites specifically there's a whole
thing you know Giardia she's other dogs
poop not to my knowledge no dogs from
the dog park that do that yeah watch out
I want to let those dog kiss you know
sometimes dogs love to like other dogs
behind
Junia she got Giardia but because we
live in the city right got a three time
so common area it projected to the wall
yeah New York City is really disgusting
and who knows there's another thing its
gram-negative bacteria called dis GaN ik
fermenter huh okay that sounds like
something that goes in here say that dog
bites you and you didn't have your
spleen that could be very dangerous to
you if that bacteria got into it it can
lead to a septic body rare fact you'd be
very very ill do dogs have spleen
yes Luci would never dream of doing that
to me well that's good to know it is
especially we like to make everything
out yes like these are my secrets dogs
can have a lot of bacteria in their
mouth will she let me look at her teeth
okay teeth there is some tartar on them
you have some tartar Wow
see all that tartar yeah because we
always worry about the tartar bacteria
going to other organs especially the
hard organs kidneys and causing
infection when dogs turn to about 80
percent of dogs have dental disease
do you ever brush her teeth we do yep
perfect how often would I say we I mean
the person at the salon doesn't let me
take her in date a haircut but
definitely should go to your vet and get
the teeth checked out before they all
start rotting away okay good okay she's
embarrassed she doesn't feel good about
this I heard that dogs mouths are
cleaner than ours no I want to go as far
as that now she's chewing on a ball
that's been all over this for the
reality is both the dog's mouth both the
humans they both have different types of
bacteria in them know about the same
probably about the same oh yeah it's not
for no reason I mean at least we're not
looking things off the streets in New
York I hope you good point no no no I
would never dream of doing that yes what
do people ever pass stuff on to their
dogs no usually cat bites are a lot
worse than dog bites their mouths
sometimes have worse bacteria but also
they have such sharp teeth
the cat so they penetrate farther into
your skin Wow
sounds like you shouldn't kiss either
but I'm gonna make an exception I said
the dog kisses make you happy they make
me very nice like if a dog does it gets
me good I'd be like well I'm kind of
gross too because apparently have the
same amount of bacteria in my mouth
right which is crazy because she spends
her day licking her butt and I do not
spend my head doing that the kissing
will probably definitely not cease I'll
just ask Lucy you know like have you
recently licked your privates before us
happen yeah and she'll definitely let me
know yeah we have we have an ongoing
dialogue I might change my mind if like
one day I have a stomachache and it
turns out to be Gerardo yeah yeah you
know until that maybe all aggressive if
I lose my spleen
maybe yeah but honestly I've never liked
her kisses like I'm not having it I'm
over kissing who do duty too many kisses
already dad who's me very embarrassing
can you give me a kiss are you too
distracted
it's not gonna happen this isn't this is
very embarrassing